the Joe Rogan experience you know the
Herschel Walker story that he actually
got jacked from doing push-ups and
sit-ups and stuff in between commercials
of shows you would watch no yes dude
that's my brain that's my brain I love I
love nothing more than a punishment
challenge like a punitive like we were
doing that one the road I was like
because Marky Mark and dr. Wahlberg dr.
oz did their push-ups I made a joke
video going there's a [ __ ] push-ups
a weird [ __ ] push-ups dude I did
[ __ ] 60 of them but why did they do
that Marky Mark is a stud push-ups were
better than dr. Oz's do you think it's
man if we call Marky Mark definitely I
got nothing but respect for him I got
another verse he's a great actor
he's on a campaign right now like he's
nothing but in my newsfeed about what
about just I don't know clear like a PR
campaign I don't know what he's I don't
know what he's well it's probably all
about him you know promoting a movie or
something like that
Spenser for hire very [ __ ]
inspirational guy he is
Boogie Nights is one of the best nights
[ __ ] ever movies ever he's got a lot
of great movies he legally legitimately
has a lot of great movies but like as a
human being like when you look at like
his dedication to fitness it's not
bullshitting he really is up at 5
o'clock in the morning work out like a
beast everybody is the real deal yeah he
is like I think if you had pivoted and
Justin acting I think you guys have
probably similar personalities like very
like hated I don't know yeah I never met
him
he was at a UFC once but I was doing
commentary and sometimes in celebrities
there I look over try to catch their eye
say hi you know I got a hug from Jeremy
Renner I was very excited really I never
met him he came over giving big hugs I
was like dude he seems like a really
cool guy he's really cool he's really
cool
but yeah more Mark Wahlberg's pitch
push-ups looked legit like kind of legit
like he's a legit stud if you look at
his workouts I mean that guy goes after
it you don't get built like that I don't
care what you're taking you don't get
built like that unless you work hard
yeah there's no magic pill that's all
hard work like whenever someone says oh
yeah they're on testosterone placement
this that's wonderful
I'm sure that helps it definitely helps
but you don't get built like that in
unless you're working out hard dr. oz oh
boy shops are [ __ ] No
mortise marks look like tricep push-ups
it's [ __ ] [ __ ] first of all the
right way to do a push-up I'm not being
a stickler but legitimately for your own
body dr. oz is actually doing it better
in that he has his elbows closer to his
body and follow me here like your hands
in front of you and this and this is a
good motion for your shoulders yeah a
lot of people think that this is a not a
good motion that this elbow out it's a
different thing and maybe it might be
better to do it the way Mark Wahlberg is
where you're not going up all the way oh
I'm sorry I got them confused dr. oz is
closer to us yes doing it right I got
them confused and he lapped him in his
polos was the mark wahlberg was doing
way better I'm sorry I said it the wrong
way I really thought that was Mark
Wahlberg in front of us for some reason
as dr. Oz says why did I think that this
is strong weed obviously the guy with
the [ __ ] hat in the gloves is wise
Marky Mark - oh my my push-ups on my
Instagram I looked at these push-ups I
was like dr. oz those aren't real
[ __ ] push-ups they're not neither one
of them are doing real push-ups do you
know that Marky Mark can he hang the
[ __ ] out probably decided they're going
for numbers and he can't lose the dr. oz
by doing legit push-ups what dr. oz
doing that was [ __ ] push-ups it's
like a strategy here's the problem with
like I love Mark Wahlberg I love him on
this podcast but he's he's not he's not
on the table the way he would be without
cameras oh yeah he's too brand friendly
I want it I want the hold he's doing
great he's doing I want to be on a
podcast don't do it I'll talk to you off
off air
[Laughter]
[Applause]